don't you go Wow Wow hey guys I'm Abbi
sharply welcome to Abby's kitchen the
temperature is definitely dropping and
the holidays are like around the corner
so if your schedules looking anything
like mine between the holiday shopping
and the entertaining you probably need a
drink so today I have you covered with
three of my all-time favorite warm and
cozy cocktails all these drinks are
completely vegan they're dairy free and
they're gluten free and they are
absolutely delish so let's do this first
up my cozy coconut cocktail to a
saucepot I add some almond coconut milk
and some unsweetened cocoa powder and I
stir it over medium heat
once the cocoa powder has dissolved I
add some spiced rum and I take it off
the heat next I pour it into my mug top
it off with some coconut whipped cream a
sprinkle of cinnamon and some toasted
coconut chips enjoy
next up my spiced pumpkin cider - a soft
pot over medium heat
yachts an apple cider some sliced ginger
and some pumpkin puree and I give
everything a good whisk until it comes
together add some bourbon off the heat
then give it a good stream and then pour
it into your serving mine top it off
with some pumpkin pie spice some apple
chips and a cinnamon stick
enjoy
[Music]
finally my dirty chai almond tea to
sauce pot I add some almond milk chai
tea bags star nice and cinnamon sticks
and I let that simmer for about five to
ten minutes then I add some maple syrup
and some Kahlua off the heat as well as
some almond creamer and they give
everything a good stir give it a strain
[Music]
then transfer the mixture to your
serving mug finish things off with a
little sprinkle of cinnamon and a
cinnamon sticks and enjoy
[Music]
the booth is here yes my friends I am
your guardian angel of the cocktail and
I have three amazing drinks here to
choose from I don't even know where to
start
but I'm gonna do a little eenie meenie
miney moe eeny meeny miny moe catch a
cocktail by the toe if he hollers let
him go eeny meeny miny moe
Oh a little chai tea action going on
here mmm mmm so good okay guys well if
you enjoyed this video be sure to give
it the thumbs up leave me a comment
below with some of your favourite
holiday or winter cozy cocktails
subscribe to the channel and I'll see
you next time on Abby's kitchen bye good
I don't think we're good I don't think
we got enough virtual drinking
[Music]